Wubbelum. Wubbelum.
Hallo.
Wubbelum.
Kungen Lockerungsübungen durchführen erstmal.
OKS.
So Leute.
Ich glaube.
Ich überlege gerade ob ich das auf.
Auf Twitter.
Ob ich das auf Twitter.
Ich glaube ich poste das mal auf Twitter.
Für Torz.
Okay.
Moin online Reda.
Wir müssen mal gucken.
Ob das passt.
Also sprich.
Die Lautstärke.
Ob die Lautstärke passt von der PS4.
Und wir müssen gucken dass der Chat nicht nervt.
Wenn der Chat nervt dann müssen wir den Chat ausmachen.
Auch wenn es Cute Chat ist.
Ja und Eier ja und alles.
Wenn das nicht funktioniert mit dem Chat.
Ja PS4 MonkaS.
Hyper MonkaS ey.
Was ein Akt gestern.
Was ein unglaublicher Riesenakt den Grams zum Laufen zu bringen.
Ich poste mal auf.
Wir müssen jetzt erstmal kurz testen ob die Lautstärke OK ist.
Ihr solltet jetzt im Hintergrund.
Ihr solltet jetzt im.
Ich glaube mein Mikro ist vielleicht ein bisschen laut.
Ne ne.
Ich habe doch seit Release eine PS4.
Ich benutze die bloß nie.
Ich benutze die ja nie.
Ich habe ewig eine.
Ich habe schon gerade eine Runde gespielt.
Das Spiel ruckelt ein bisschen.
Aber das glaube ich nicht dass es an der PS4 liegt.
Das wird einfach am Game liegen.
Ihr solltet jetzt im Hintergrund.
Müsstet ihr leise den PS4 Menü Sound hören.
Ne was heißt kein einziges Game installiert außer Modern Warfare.
Doch doch.
Doch doch klar.
Das Problem ist nur.
Ich erzähle euch das jetzt mal kurz bevor wir anfangen.
Ich muss gleich meine Hände fäschen.
Meine Hände sind übelst bappig.
Ich habe hier so eine uralte Gammel Maus jetzt angeschlossen am anderen Rechner.
Ähm.
Ich muss euch das jetzt mal kurz erzählen.
Das ist ein Akt.
Wir starten das jetzt gerade mal.
Können wir jetzt gerade mal gucken wie die Lautstärke ist.
Das Ruckel ist wohl ein Bug von der Map.
Ich glaube das ruckelt überall.
Ja wir warten erst mal mit Twitter Message posten.
Bis ähm.
Bis ich ein paar Runden gespielt habe.
Erinnert mich mal bitte daran.
Ist ja gut.
Wir haben mehr Krach.
Ich glaube es könnte tatsächlich ein bisschen laut sein.
Wenn es ein bisschen laut ist muss ich.
Kein Pepo Clap.
Kein Pepo Clap habe ich nicht gefunden.
Muss Link schicken.
Also jetzt pass mal auf.
Riesenakt mit der Playstation.
Ich habe mich gestern versucht anzumelden.
Ich habe die Playstation 4 erst mal seit 3 Jahren wieder eingeschaltet.
Ja.
Das ist ja ewig her.
Seit Ewigkeiten habe ich das Ding wieder eingeschaltet.
Und dann habe ich festgestellt.
Oh ich muss erst mal eine Stunde lang Updates machen.
Ja nice.
Stunde lang Updates.
Alles gut.
Und dann war das Problem.
Das Ding wollte sich ins PSN verbinden.
Und es konnte sich nicht mit dem PSN verbinden.
Ging nicht.
Keine PSN Verbindung möglich.
Was ist das?
Hat so eine Nachricht angezeigt.
Ja ich könnte ja mein Passwort resetten.
Vielleicht wurde der Account gesperrt.
Was auch immer.
Was eigentlich vollkommener Blödsinn ist.
Vielleicht hätte ich eine Nachricht kriegen müssen per Mail.
Aber nö.
Wollten wir nicht.
In der Mail auf den Link geklickt.
Zum Thema Passwort resetten.
Und da wollten die mein Geburtsdatum wissen.
Bei Sony.
Mein Geburtsdatum.
Was weiß ich.
Was ich bei diesem Kack Fake Account für ein Geburtsdatum eingetragen habe.
Gut.
Konnte ich nicht resetten.
Okay.
Also.
Ich habe gedacht.
Scheiß drauf.
Resettest du deine PS4.
Das alles runter ist.
Dann meldest du dich im neuen Account an.
Dann ist mir aufgefallen.
Das ist Big Brain Play von Sony.
Huge.
Also Five Head.
Übrigens wir haben unser erstes Emote.
Mach mal Wupplull.
Wupplull gibt es jetzt im Emote.
Ja.
Ging nicht.
Man muss sich anmelden.
Dankeschön.
Ich habe leider kein Meme Board heute am Start.
Aber ich habe noch ein paar Monate.
Ultra Poggers.
Casino Kapitalist auch am Start.
Sehr nice.
Naja zumindest man muss sich anmelden.
Das ist richtig Huge Brain von Sony.
Man muss sich anmelden um seine PS4 resetten zu können.
Also sprich.
Wenn man die PS4 resetten will.
Wenn man den Account verloren hat.
Dann geht das Ganze nicht.
Ja.
Ich glaube der Sound ist ein bisschen laut.
Das Main Menu.
Warte mal.
Wenn das Main Menu schon so laut ist.
So.
Dann wird das andere auch zu laut sein.
Naja zumindest.
Also da habe ich festgestellt man kann bei der PS4 einen zweiten Account anmelden.
Habe ich mir gerade scheiß drauf.
Du machst hier einen zweiten Account.
Habe ich mir einen zweiten PSN Account gemacht.
Angemeldet. Bin in den Playstation Store gegangen.
Und habe festgestellt Modern Warfare ist nicht runterladbar.
Ne ne das ist das Hauptmenü.
Modern Warfare ist nicht runterladbar.
Warum?
Das weiß man nicht.
Weil Sony der Meinung ist in Deutschland geht das nicht.
Man kann das nicht runterladen.
Man kann das nicht.
Man kann das nicht runterladen in Deutschland.
Ohne Playstation Plus.
Sie haben im Vorfeld.
Sie haben im Vorfeld einen riesen Hack gemacht.
So nach dem Motto jeder kann es spielen.
Jeder kann es spielen.
Vollkommen egal.
Und in Deutschland geht das nur mit Playstation Plus.
Na Typ schrick.
Ich habe nichts weitergeleitet auf die Playstation.
Warum soll ich da was weiterleiten.
Habe ich festgestellt.
Gut geht nicht.
Und wollte ich.
Ich wollte mir tatsächlich mal ganz kurz überlegt.
Wollte ich mir.
Ich habe mein Bildschirm irgendwie auf den falschen Monitor umgeschaltet.
Warte mal kurz.
Und dann wollte ich mir PS Plus kaufen.
Ein Monat. Einfach zum runterladen.
Weil ich keinen Bock hatte auf einen weiteren Akt.
Und dann habe ich festgestellt.
Oh geht ja nicht.
Ich muss irgendwie meinen Ausweis einscannen oder sowas.
Irgendwas mit meinem Ausweis wollten sie haben.
Und dann habe ich gesagt.
Gut wisst ihr was.
Ihr könnt mich mal voll am Arsch lecken Sony.
Und Infiniti.
Ihr könnt mich alle am Arsch lecken.
Ich mache mir jetzt einfach noch einen dritten Account.
An diesem Tag.
Den zweiten Account an diesem Tag.
Und habe dort eingestellt.
Ich wohne in England in London im Burger King.
Und ich heiße Max Omega Poggers.
Und das haben die gefressen.
Das haben den Account mit angelegt.
Und dann konnte ich es runterladen.
Und dann habe ich vier Stunden.
Vier Stunden gestern gebraucht.
Bis ich das Game unten hatte.
Und da sagt noch mal einer.
Konsole ist einfacher als PC.
Dankeschön.
Es kann sein, dass ich das heute nicht so richtig sehe.
Mit den Emotes.
Weil ich gucke hier auf dem zweiten Monitor.
Wo ich halt kein Chat habe.
Trotzdem Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich gehe jetzt mal ganz schnell Hände waschen.
Und dann spielen wir.
Waschen Alter. Waschen.
Hat der Waschen gesagt?
Ja heute ist mein Waschtag.
Einmal im Monat.
Einmal im Monat kann ich.
Sonst geht man nicht als echter Gamer durch.
Ist das Game P2P oder was?
Wegen Nutt.
Ich habe nicht den leisesten Schimmer einer Ahnung.
Aber wir spielen jetzt die Runde.
Auf geht's Leute.
Waschen Alter. Waschen.
Waschen.
Okay.
Ahem.
Den Ball.
Waschen.
Aber bitte nicht.
Ob die das prohibited.
Bei.
Maschen.
Aber waschen.
Waschen.
Maschen.
Habt ihr gesehen, wie sie ruckelt?
Da vorne war er.
Huge Rush.
Huge Big Brain.
Rekt.
Easy Clap.
Okay.
Was ist denn der beste Weg hier?
Ich renn mal außen rum.
Ich mein Pump Action.
Da kann nicht so viel passieren.
Wow, was?
Was zum Teufel?
Warum hat er eine Pistole?
What the fuck?
Ah, Secondary.
Ah, Smart.
Huge.
Big Play.
Pass mal auf, wir werden jetzt so krass auen noch.
Also es ist nicht mit Maus, es ist nur mit Controller.
Sei denn, du hast irgendeinen Adapter, der das emuliert.
Ach, wir haben gewonnen.
Mein Teammate.
Oh, es geht ab.
Der Beast Aim.
Beast Aim carried mich.
3 zu 0.
Igitt.
Warum trifft...
Alter, was zum Teufel?
Ich blick nicht durch.
Der hat...
Outplayed.
Ich muss mich erstmal ein bisschen einspielen.
Aber der Beast Aim.
Guckt euch das Beast...
Guckt euch den Beast Aim an.
Beast Aim.
Guck mal, der...
Der geht ab.
Das ist bestimmt hier...
Wir haben eine X-Solution oder irgendwas.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es den noch gibt.
Achtung, jetzt, jetzt wird es...
Wreckt.
Weggeskillt.
Das ruckelt?
Was ist das denn?
Das ist...
Äh.
Wait, what?
Ich weiß nicht mal, was der Knopf ist zum Messern.
Ist das Alpha?
Alpha ist das.
Ist das ein Schneiber?
Schneiber-End?
Schneiber?
Rekt.
Die kriegen auf den Sack, ey.
Schnibber.
Das war...
Habe ich das richtig gesehen?
Eine 30-Schuss-Auto-Sniper?
Eine 30-Schuss-Silenced-Auto-Sniper?
Ist das euer Ernst, ja?
Ich schneiber die jetzt wieder in Spawn.
Ich geh oben lang.
Oh, oh, jetzt rusht er.
Jetzt rusht er.
Naja.
4, 2, 7.
Der Beast-Aim, der will es wissen.
Ach, ach, es ist nur noch einer.
Der ist gelieft.
6-0.
Gleich mal.
Bam, ba-ba-bam.
Das ist eigentlich ein Sturmgewehr, okay.
Ach so.
Poggers, Poggers ist am Start.
LOL, weh.
Ach nee, nicht LOL, weh.
Wupp, lull.
Wie ist das Game?
Das ist die zweite Runde.
Wie findest du die Modes?
Ich hab noch so gut wie nicht gespielt.
Oh, jetzt haben wir wieder so ein komisches...
A-C-O-G.
Hey, Desert Eagle-Ding.
Passt auf, Leute, ich sag euch jetzt.
Wir strafen jetzt, wir hardscopen jetzt und strafen und headshotten den Dude across the map.
Ich sag's euch, ich sag's euch.
Pass auf, pass auf.
Rekt.
Oh, fuck, das ist gar nicht One-Shot, das Ding.
Jetzt aber.
Bam, in the face, Alter.
Ja.
Wie heilt man sich?
Ich gewinne.
Easy.
Man gewinnt, wenn man mehr Leben hat als die Gegner.
Wow.
Der hat übelst gelaggt.
Guckt euch mal an, Alter.
Guckt euch mal an.
Hallo?
Jawoll, easy win.
Ich find das...
Das hat was, dass man keine Leben...
Das hat was, dass man seine Leben nicht regenerieren kann.
Weil dadurch bringt das was, wenn du die Gegner low schießt.
Der konnte jetzt einfach One-Shotten, weil ich den Vorschau mal getroffen hab.
Das ist eigentlich übelst nice.
Oh, was?
Ist der denn da durchgelaufen jetzt?
Ist nur in dem Modus mit dem heilen, okay.
Ich hab halt null Ahnung, wo mein Langhand ist.
Oh, mein Langhand.
Okay, die Dinger sind deaktiviert.
Was zum Teufel?
Bin ich zu dumm zum zielen auf den, oder was?
Hat man ne Ping-Anzeige?
The fuck?
Das war doch drauf, oder?
Ja, okay, ich bin echt...
Ich glaub, ich bin einfach zu dumm zum zielen.
Kann sein.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich.
Ist mal 1-3, das ist...
Oh, was ist das hier?
Shotgun.
Au.
The fuck?
Alter.
Die auen uns übelst weg.
Ping-Anzeige gibt's nicht.
Okay.
Wo ist, wo, wo ist denn der, der, der Beast-Aimer hin?
Der Beast-Aimer hat uns eben übelst gecarried.
Oh.
Oben, oben unten.
Wo haben wir?
Oh.
Okay, komm.
Leute.
Mal zusammenreißen hier.
Ich glaube, es ist immer zwei Hunden mit der gleichen Waffe.
Wir rushen jetzt die Mitte lang.
Passt mal auf.
Übelst huge, huge, huge.
Huge play.
W...
Was zum...
Ich hab nur einmal geschossen, der hat doppelt geschossen.
Habt ihr das gesehen gerade?
Man...
Alter, man kann die Gegner nicht orten.
Okay, was auch immer.
Schießt man zwei Schuss, wenn man irgendwie durchgedrückt hält oder so?
Habt ihr das gerade gesehen?
Ich hab einmal geschossen, es waren zwei Schuss weg und der Gegner nicht tot?
Irgendwie ganz merkwürdig.
Oh, fuck.
Jetzt geht das schon los.
Ach, scheiße, Mann.
Easy.
Ach, der ist wieder gelieft.
Was sind das für ehrenlose Gegner, ey?
Okay, jetzt wissen wir das.
Ehrenlose Gegner.
Ne, das letzte Mal, der ist gelieft, nachdem die Runde vorbei war.
Das letzte Mal ist gelieft, nachdem die Runde vorbei war.
Das letzte Mal war okay.
Spielst du mit Maus und Tastatur?
Ich hab das vorhin mit diesem komischen Adapter probiert.
Das ist irgendwie...
Merkwürdig.
Wie du Secondary...
Stimmt nicht an, ein RPG als Secondary.
Bleibt man jetzt eigentlich in der Runde?
Ja.
Bleibt man jetzt eigentlich in der Lobby?
Wenn man jetzt einfach nur hier im Chat rumgammelt?
Guck mal zurück.
Ich mag übrigens den Sound überhaupt nicht irgendwie.
Also zwingend...
Aber die Analogsticks von PS4-Controllern...
Bluep, ja genau.
Wow.
Ich dachte schon, wir spielen nur gegen einen.
Es gibt hier bestimmt übelst nice Nadespots.
Wir rennen jetzt außen rum.
Ganz schnell!
Meine Güte, ey
Übelste Kack, ey
Mit dem PS4-Controller
Wow, es spricht, es spricht
Sekunde, Leute, wartet mal
Es spricht
Hardscope
Wo ist der Dude?
Das macht mir jetzt
Das ist immer das Wichtigste in COD
Stats checken, permanent Stats checken
Oh
Ach, wieder so eine Duel-Dings
Achtung
Oh, ne
Wir haben uns getrennt, das ist ein Shot
Alter
Ach, scheiße
Ich spiele aktuell eigentlich kaum noch Shooter-mäßig
Ich merke das auch, dass ich irgendwie
Hab keine Übung mehr hab
Aber, wenn wir das jetzt ein paar Tage
Grinden, dann sind wir wieder
Poggers
Ja, was? Au
Komm raus, komm raus, Alter, komm raus
Puh
Echt?
Ah
Oh, oh, ein, ein, ein nicer Messerkill
Ohne Messer
Was ist das?
Ist, ist, ist das jetzt eine Shotgun?
Ich erkenne die Kackwaffen nicht
Ich glaube, das ist eine Shotgun
Oder auch nicht, was ist das?
Was ist das?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ist das für eine Waffe?
Ist das eine Shotgun?
MK-2
Okay, ich schreibe das mal meinem Dude hinterher
Ich glaube, das ist irgendeine Singleschusswaffe
Pff, ey
Okay
Da bin ich, das ist zu, zu small brain für die Waffe
Small brain
Oh, jetzt gibt's hier LMG-Action
Oh, fuck, in der Mitte
Oh, shit
Heal, ich brauch heal
Ah, shit
Komm, Alter, du machst das
Jawoll, bam
So ist gut
Ich muss mal gucken, dass man
Die Maps, die Map irgendwie mal ein bisschen zu seinem Vorteil ausspielt
So dieses, dieses sinnlos
Langrushen ist
Ah, links finde ich gut
Links hat was
Ich bin so scheiße in Games mittlerweile
Alter, ist das schlecht
Ich kann mal das in den Akku
Oh, dabei hätte ich den übelst
Mein
Egal, wir gewinnen das noch
Ich sag's euch, Leute, wir kreiten das Game jetzt mal ordentlich
Und morgen oder die nächsten Tage, wir werden so krass gebasht
Wenn wir mal wieder ein bisschen Übung haben
Das Bild kommt verzögert vom Sound
Ähm
Vom Sound zum
Ach so, meine Stimme
Ja, das kann sein
Da muss ich mich selbst ein bisschen verzögern
Mann, ich war doch drauf, Alter
Das, das liegt
Ich, das kann sein
Weil das über die Elgato geht
Und die Elgato hat so eine halbe Sekunde Verzögerung
Ich guck mal, dass ich mich ein bisschen verzögern kann
Gleich, wenn, wenn das hier fertig ist
Oder ist das jetzt fertig?
Ich will so eine Runde spielen
Dann, dann stell ich das ein
Ich versuch mich ein bisschen zu verzögern gleich
Wir machen jetzt noch eine Runde und dann, dann
Dann probier ich das mal
Wobei
Wartet mal
Input
Displayport
Jetzt muss ich halt umstöpseln
Wow, schack
Meine Güte, ey
Ich schmeiß immer diese Verlängerung von meinem Headset runter
Ich hoffe, euch sind jetzt nicht direkt die Ohren weggeflogen
Ähm
So, ich versuch mich mal einen Ticken zu verzögern
Wie geht denn das jetzt hier?
Mic
Properties
Filter
Delay
Okay, nope
Ich muss umschalten
Ich stell's gleich um
Ich muss irgendwo mal gucken, wie das geht
Nö, das Game hat keine Musik
Oh, wieder diese komische
Komische Schneibe-End
Fuck
Äh
Schön an der Wand
Okay, das Ding bringt das Wasser ab einer gewissen Range
Und manchmal scheint es besser zu sein, wenn man
Jetzt wird gerusht
Jetzt wird es gebasht
Könnt ihr mal sterben bitte?
Oh, Mann
Okay, das muss man anders spielen
Aber unser Dude gewinnt das
Wir gewinnen das
Wenn er einfach nix macht
Ja, das OBS
Ich glaube, ich weiß, wie das geht
Da muss ich, da muss ich in die
In die, in die Übertragung-Settings
Das geht nicht über irgendwelche Filter
Wo ist der andere Dude?
Ach, da ist ein Ob-
Oh, fuck
Da ist ein Objective in der Mitte
Oh, man
Das ist übelst der Noob-Style
Ich will mich bewegen
Please
Na gut, der hat mich jetzt einfach nicht gesehen
Schön von der Seite
weggesnackt, ey.
Wupp, lull.
Das ist doch Wahnsinn, wie schlecht man werden kann, ey.
Vor allem, wenn man auf der Plattform
nicht spielt.
Man hört die Gegner irgendwie komisch.
Rechts.
Wer war er?
Okay, 3-3. Wir haben aufgeholt, Leute.
MP5. Jetzt geht's ab.
Meine Güte, ey.
Also entweder ist meine Reaktion
mittlerweile mega beschissen.
Ach nee, ich hab bei ihm gar nicht geschossen.
Oder es ist einfach huge Host-Vorteil
des Todes, ey.
Aber ich glaub, meine Reaktion ist einfach beschissen.
Achso, fuck, man hat ja gar keine.
Jetzt machen wir huge. Pass auf. Huge play.
Richtig huge play.
Richtig massive, massive play.
Ich glaube,
dass der Modus, wenn man den mit jemanden
spielt, mit dem man
irgendwie auch im Discord ist oder so,
ist das, glaub ich, gar nicht so dumm.
Pass auf, jetzt wird er geheadshottet.
Okay.
Hast du schon mal überlegt, eSport,
mit meiner krassen Performance,
hier ist es ja auch...
Fabian will nicht spielen.
Ups. Fabian will nicht.
Wartet mal.
Was ist denn hier? Was gibt's denn hier eigentlich?
Clan-Tag?
Falling Cards? Achso, das ist die übliche
Geschichte hier.
Emblems. Kann man wieder Custom-Emblems
machen? Loadouts
gibt's nicht, weil Gunfight?
Hat man eigentlich einen Rang?
Hab ich schon irgendwie einen Rang?
Profile.
X.
Ich darf mein Profile nicht viewen.
Mein Profile gibt's nicht zu viewen.
Oh, wieder.
Buckel-Map.
Level 1, okay.
Also ich glaube, auf der Map ist es
vorzulaufen zum Auto gar nicht so übel.
Wie geht eigentlich, wie kann man eigentlich
diesen Super-Rennen machen und so?
Okay.
Wo ist der Dude?
Ach, weiß.
Das sieht doch übelst verwaschen aus.
Na gut, das könnte auch bei mir ein bisschen am Stream liegen, oder?
Aber ich glaub, der Stream sieht eigentlich ganz gut aus.
Das ruckelt voll, die Map.
Was ist da los?
Der andere war in der Mitte.
Ist der Typ AFK?
Also nicht meiner und auch nicht der.
Der andere, der steht immer im Spawn
und macht nix.
Ich glaub, der ist AFK, der Typ.
Ich glaub, der ist AFK.
Sind die beide AFK?
Ich glaub, die sind jetzt einfach beide Rage-Quitted.
Ach, oh Gott.
Das ist wieder ehrenlose Runde.
Äh.
Der andere ist schon wieder gelieft.
Wisst ihr was?
Jetzt kann ich mal testen, was das für eine Waffe ist.
Ob das jetzt ne Shotgun ist, oder?
Ne, das ist ein Single-Schuss.
Single-Schuss, ähm.
So ein bisschen was wie ne Sniper.
So sieht das aus.
So sieht das aus wie ne Shotgun.
Ja, die one-shottet auch.
Okay, der Dude ist eh AFK.
Toll.
Tolle Runde.
Wahnsinns-Win.
Sind die 48 FPS Cap auf dem Stream gewollt?
Ja.
Sind gewollt.
Reicht und braucht weniger Bandbreite.
Muss nämlich grad mal was gucken in der Vorschau.
Weil ich glaub, der Stream sieht ganz okay aus.
Ja, ich seh's grad in der Vorschau.
Der Stream sieht echt ganz in Ordnung aus.
Aber das sieht bei mir übrigens auch verwaschen aus.
Ne, das liegt nicht am Stream.
Wieso kann er spielen?
Weil ich ne PS4 hab.
Und jeder auf der PS4 die Alpha kostenlos spielen kann.
Allerdings.
Oh, wieder beste Merkwürde.
Oh, wie der beste Merkwürde.
Allerdings, dieses Problem ist in Deutschland.
Du brauchst PS Plus.
Wobei die restliche Welt...
Oh, der Baumstamm sieht gut aus.
Die restliche Welt braucht kein PS Plus.
PlayStation Plus.
Die restliche Welt ist da ein bisschen weiter als wir.
So, wir rushen jetzt zum Auto vor, Leute.
Sliden. Sliden.
Und sehen nix.
Fuck.
Fuck man, wo ist der Dude?
Aha, da ist er.
Da war er.
Kaufst du dir eigentlich ne PS5 oder ne Xbox Ultimate?
Ich weiß nicht.
Also, ich war ja recht enttäuscht von der letzten Konsolengeneration.
Hab ich ja schon ein paar mal erzählt.
Die hab ich mir zum Release gekauft.
Und deswegen werd ich mir warten.
Ich werd diesmal warten.
Das hat sich für mich überhaupt nicht gelohnt.
Die Xbox One und ähm...
Ist das wieder die Schneiber, oder?
Die One-Shot-Schneiber.
Alter, man kann sich null bewegen, ne?
Da ist schon wieder gelieft, der Typ.
Was ist das? Was sind das für Gegner?
Was sind das für Gegner?
Wie macht man eigentlich Supersprint?
Äh, Options?
Man kann doch irgendwie Supersprinten.
Kommt das automatisch?
Hat er irgendeine Ahnung?
Wenn man einfach nur lang genug sprintet vielleicht?
Was war das denn?
Vielleicht...
Linken Stick reindrücken?
Also quasi, quasi...
Okay, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Wenn Linken Stick reindrücken ist...
Ich halte Linken Stick jetzt gedrückt, da passiert überhaupt nichts.
Komisch.
Oder zweimal Linken Stick nach vorn.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich hab...
Kein Schimmer.
Ja, und übrigens, das Game hat wirklich keine Musik.
Null. Außer im Hauptmenü.
Sonst hat's null.
Sonst hat es null Musik.
Weder im Menü noch sonstwo.
Ja, Microtransaction...
Dings...
Snoop Dogg Music DLC.
Ach, guck mal hier.
Jump...
Tactical...
Flip...
Sprint...
Supersprint. Alter, Playstation.
Band, ich war zu gut.
Ah...
You must be signed in the Playstation Network.
Ich bin in Playstation Network ingesigned.
Dachte ich zumindest.
Ich glaub PSN kackt grad wieder ab.
Ey, wie das ruckelt.
So.
Oh, da müsst ihr mir jetzt mal helfen.
Ähm...
Wie beendet man auf der Playstation Games?
Dreieck?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie geht denn das?
Options, Options.
Close.
Ah...
Da seht ihr mal, wie oft ich auf dieser Plattform unterwegs bin.
Weiß nicht mal, wie man Games beendet.
Wie ist übrigens die Ingame-Lautstärke so jetzt gewesen?
Ist das okay?
Moment, ich wollte mich ja noch verzögern.
Das mach ich jetzt mal, bevor es losgeht.
xFaceless17, dankeschön, Twitch Prime.
Okay, ähm...
Input, ich muss mich mal kurz auf den PC umstellen.
Und, ähm...
Okay...
Ich verzöger mal mein Mikrofon ein bisschen.
Audio...
Oh fuck, das geht gar nicht da, wo ich dachte.
Advanced...
Weiß...
Nee, hier konnte man sich...
Ich weiß genau, das ging.
Das ging irgendwo in den Mixer oder irgendwo.
Sync Offset, hier ist es.
Mik Aux.
Okay, Sync Offset.
Das heißt, ich mach das jetzt mal
500, 500 Millisekunden...
Wir sind auf Twitch, ja.
Ich mach das jetzt mal 500 Millisekunden langsamer.
Und dann müssen wir mal gucken, wie es funktioniert.
Dann müssen wir mal gucken, wie ich...
Ob ich jetzt irgendwie verzögerter bin.
Sollte jetzt besser passen.
So, ich müsste jetzt 500 Millisekunden verzögert sein.
Wollen wir da Monitor umschalten?
Mal gucken, ob es besser funktioniert.
Wubblull.
Für was willst du überhaupt verzögern?
Ich will mein Mikrofon 500 Millisekunden verzögern.
Ähm...
Damit ich...
Zum Gamesound passend bin.
Alter, Monitor, schalt mal auf die PS4 um.
Der ist klar, hab ich net.
Drückstens halt mit so nem Xim-Adapter.
Wobei das Gefühl war ganz merkwürdig.
Wird auch erkannt, ja, aber nicht in Games, das wär...
Okay, perfekt.
Okay, der andere ist links.
Pst, pst, pst, pst.
Der campt auch.
Schreckt!
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen,
dass man ingame direkt an die Playstation
per Maus und Tastatur spielen kann.
Huge.
Na, langsam werden wir warm, hä?
Bam, bop, bop, bam.
Easy win, easy life.
Ja, es ist halt ein bisschen
langsamer, als man jetzt irgendwie Call of Duty Deathmatch
gewöhnt ist. Es gibt nur
zwei Maps, es gibt nichts, außer diesen
Modus und irgendwie drei Maps.
Achso, jetzt machen wir Big Play.
Big Play.
Der kennt sich da hinten einen ab, oder?
Oh, fuck. War das hinter uns?
Was zum Teufel?
Ich war da zwei Sekunden
vorher drauf.
Na gut, das war halt durch die Wand, durch die Wand macht weniger
Damage. Okay, das hat mir gefallen.
Geh jetzt in die Mitte.
Nein, nein, fuck, shit.
Outplayed.
Okay, es ist auf jeden Fall eine ziemlich doofe Idee,
loszurennen. Man muss
auf dem Weg bleiben, wo man am Anfang langgelaufen
ist. Doch, die Waffen haben sogar
halbwegs Rückstoß.
Alter, meine Güte.
Gibt's nicht. Mein PS4-Aim
ist so mega für den Arsch, ey.
Okay. Wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen
CS-Style machen. Da war er, oder?
Da war er doch.
Aber eine Ping-Anzeige
wäre trotzdem nicht schlecht.
Eine Ping-Anzeige hätte schon was, ne?
Der wartet hier auf mich jetzt.
Das...
Also ich glaube, das ist wirklich gut, wenn man
das mit jemandem spielt zusammen,
wo man kommunizieren kann, weil so hat man
ja absolut keine Ahnung.
Ob hinter einem frei ist oder nicht.
Also man kann eigentlich geradeaus
rushen und gut ist. Also irgendwelche Sachen,
weil du hast keine Infos halt.
Ich hör nix.
Man hört die Gegner ganz merkwürdig.
Der wollte
dropshotten. Wollte der dropshotten, der Typ?
Ich glaube, der wollte dropshotten.
Der gerade Dropshotter war das.
Easy. Easy win.
Wie gefällt dir MW bisher?
Ähm, eigentlich...
Naja, das kann man schlecht sagen.
Die Cods machen immer Bock am Anfang.
Ich glaube, der Modus ist
nicht dafür gemacht, mit Randoms zu spielen.
Das mit dem XIM hat geklappt.
Ich mach das jetzt.
Ich mach das jetzt. Ich stöpsel jetzt gleich mal
auf den XIM. Aber das Problem ist,
dass sich das ganz merkwürdig anfühlt mit
Maus und Tastatur. Emuliert
irgendwie. Wir probieren das. Wir probieren
das jetzt mal aus.
Ich mach jetzt... Komm nicht in die Server ran.
Du musst das Game beenden.
Okay.
Also, Leute.
Das machen wir mal.
Ich hab das ja noch angeschlossen. Deswegen kann ich auch so
schlecht mein XIM.
Ähm, ich mach das jetzt mal.
Also.
Dann muss ich erst mal die XIM-App aufmachen.
Oh, fuck.
Äh, klar.
Ich mach das jetzt. Ich mach das jetzt.
Achtung. Passt, passt. Ich hab's gleich.
So.
Profil geladen. Wartet mal.
Okay. Okay.
Oh, fuck.
Na, toll. Jetzt wollte ich gerade ranrutschen
mit dem Stuhl.
Lol.
Ich brauch keinen Emulator. Echt? Man kann in den Einstellungen
auf Tastatur und Maus stellen? Wirklich?
Probieren wir danach aus.
Jetzt will ich erst mal diesen komischen
Adapter testen. Ja, aber ich glaube,
wenn du mit Maus und Tastatur spielst,
da wirst du... Na, wobei. Ist doch egal.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, man wird nur mit Maus und Tastatur
Leuten gematcht. Aber das ist ja egal. Die spielen ja alle auf der PS4.
Oh, das ist übelst gewöhnungsbedürftig,
Leute. Hai, jai, jai.
Übelster Hardscoper.
Aha.
Schön haben wir vorbeigelaufen.
Das wird angezeigt. Wer mit Maus...
Mit was spiele ich gerade? Wo sieht man das?
Ach, hier unten.
Mit dem Controller. Close.
Oder?
Ja, eins.
Jetzt geht's ab.
Au. Ich hab mir gerade Orangensaft ins Gesicht
gespritzt.
Oh, das brennt übelst.
Boca S.
Was ist das da?
Pschu, pschu, pschu, pschu, pschu.
Oh, fuck.
Säure im Auge ist super, super angenehm.
Okay, die sind links.
Kann ich rennen?
Der kommt jetzt hinter mir. Pass auf, da wird das geownt.
War vielleicht der Wallhack oder was?
Was? Ich hab gewonnen? Ach, der ist gelieft.
Der ist gelieft. Deswegen.
Wieso gehst du immer auf und ab?
Was meinst du?
Weil ich Crap Movement auf der Konsole hab.
Ach so, auf und ab?
Weil ich denke, dass das mehr bringt.
Ich denke. Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das wirklich so ist.
Für die 60!
7-1. Huge Gameplay.
Direkt YouTube-Upload.
2 gegen 1.
Wieso eigentlich 48 Bilder pro Sekunde?
Weil das menschliche Auge nur 24 sehen kann.
Und ich hab gedacht, wenn man die doppelte
Anzahl davon nimmt, dann ist auch
für beide Augen ruckelfrei.
Nee, zum Bandbreite sparen.
Big Brain Fivehead.
Ah ja, Leute. Übrigens passt jetzt mein Gelaber
vom Sound her besser zum Game?
Seid ich's? Ich hab's ja, ich hab's ja verzögert.
50 Millisekunden.
Jetzt sollte, sollte es besser hin, hinhauen.
Weil die Klappe.
Ich glaube, es müsste jetzt besser passen, wenn ich die 500 Millisekunden nicht verzögert hab.
Oh.
Deckelige Luke.
Okay, wo gehen wir denn jetzt hier lang?
Wir machen jetzt hier uns, wir machen jetzt unseren, wir machen jetzt den, den, den, den.
Rush B. Rush B. Taktik.
Hits. Der hat Hits.
Okay, Hits ansagen bringt hier ja nur wirklich nix.
Oh, oh, oh.
Huge.
Solo.
Geowned.
Die Plays sind real, ich sag's euch.
Oh, oh.
Monka S.
Monka S. Wo kam der denn her?
Kollege, du bist vollkommen...
Oh, da ist er.
Was war...
Wie sie rumruckelt.
P2P-Hosting in 2019.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Oh, MP5.
Achtung hier.
Oh, hü.
Easy Solo-Carrier.
Damn.
5-1, so ist das gut.
So mag ich das.
P2P.
Ich glaube, dass es P2P ist.
Die geben uns ja keine Ping-Anzeige.
Haha, Kollege, so nicht.
Den hat man gut...
Die Map finde ich gut.
Die Map ruckelt nicht so.
Und ich hab das Gefühl, auf der Map kann man auch die Gegner besser orten vom Sound her.
Diese Wald-Map ist der übelste Bodensatz.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das Server sind.
Ich glaube nicht.
Okay, das war zu übertrieben.
Das war zu in your face.
Ich bin in beide reingerannt.
Das war nix.
Das war voll übermütig jetzt.
Ich dachte mir, übelste Kack-Noobs einfach mal reinrushen.
Aber der Luke macht es schon jetzt.
Was ruckelt?
Seht ihr, wie krass der Typ abruckelt?
Leg-Switch am Start, hä?
Er hat erstmal schön den Leg-Switch angemacht.
Wir machen jetzt mal was.
Pass mal auf.
Jutsch.
Jetzt ist es Big-Brain-Play.
Bam.
Schreckt.
Rush B.
P90 war das.
Direkt durch die Mitte.
Und ruff.
Wublul.
Oh ne, jetzt haben wir wieder so ne Kack-Waffe am Start.
Einfach linke Seite.
Da kommt schon einer, ich seh es.
Oh fuck.
Pfeifherd.
Ähm.
Tracking.
Track, attack, protec...
Pro...
Protect, attack, track.
Meine Güte.
Du schreckst ja alles in dem Game, ja.
Naja, wenn ich nicht mehr mit dem PS4-Controller spielen muss,
das ist jetzt kein Problem.
Kama Sutra.
Seht ihr mal, wie...
...merkwürdig die Schrift aussieht?
Die sieht übelst kaputt aus, die Schrift.
Ist das als COD 4 Remake gedacht?
Nee, das ist was eigenständiges.
Das Ding heißt wahrscheinlich Modern Warfare,
weil man damit gut Geld verdienen kann.
Oh, das ist die Waffe.
Okay.
Also, wir gehen jetzt auf die...
Wir gehen jetzt auf die Dinger hier.
Und own den.
Und da sehen wir auch gleich, ob es ein Stream-Sniper ist.
So.
Ha!
Schreckt, Alter.
Voll in den Kopf.
Nein!
Shit.
Aber ich hab...
Ich hab ihn getaggt.
Komm, Kollege, du machst das.
Du machst das, Alter.
Du machst das.
Jawoll!
Schreckt.
Sehr gut.
Weggecockt.
Warum wallhack?
Das ist nur beim Spawn einmalig.
Wir gehen jetzt wieder auf die...
Okay.
Der kommt bestimmt von links.
Ich sag's euch.
Oh, ne.
Okay.
Macht er nicht.
Ich glaube, man kann mit dieser Waffe viel schneller schießen,
als ich so gedacht hab.
Ich hoffe, wir spielen noch eine Runde mit der...
Ah, nee.
Jetzt machen wir was.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt machen wir was.
Jetzt werden sie outplayed.
Outplayed.
Scheiße!
Fuck!
Ah!
Das hätte so gut klappen können.
Ich bin voll...
Oh Gott, ich bin...
Das...
Das hätte richtig gut klappen können.
Was ist eigentlich auf der Tastatur?
Messern.
Granaten könnte ich noch mal ein bisschen mehr verwenden.
Gib mir dem ab.
Ich habe übrigens immer noch nicht gecheckt, wie ich Supersprint mache.
Jawoll!
Und?
Das ist...
Das sieht aus wie Killer House von COD 4.
Ah!
So.
Ach, meine Güte, ey.
Ich spiel viel...
Ich...
Ich bin...
Ich bin voll sinnlos am reinrushen gerade, ey.
Weil wir die letzten Runden so geowned haben, denke ich mir jetzt die ganze Zeit so...
Ah ja, YOLO drauf wird schon.
Ein bisschen ordentlicher spielen.
Okay, jetzt habe ich gecheckt, wie man sprintet.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Aber der...
Der...
Der Rot...
Der Riot, der Carry-Ons.
Riot Carry-Ons.
Äh...
Ist der SMG, hä?
P7?
P7 klingt nach SMG.
Oh, meine Güte, ey.
Ich höre die nicht.
Hörst du?
Null.
Und der hat mich auch nicht gehört.
Ey, der Typ geht ab.
Der Riot.
Der geht übelst ab.
Riot geht...
Der geht...
Der Audi.
WAH!
Wat?
Okay.
Das ist...
Das ist Killer House aus COD 4.
Sieht auch genau aus irgendwie wie Killer House.
Oh, jetzt kommt die LMG.
LMG legit.
2-5-8.
Ah, dafür haben wir letzte Runde übelst geowned.
Bam.
Jo.
Gut.
So geht's auch.
LMG legit.
Ja, LMG kann er.
Ich hab das Movement halt null raus irgendwie mit...
Auf der PS4.
Also generell.
Das hab ich ja eben noch mal gespielt.
LMG legit.
Das kann er.
Rechts ist...
Die sind rechts.
What?
Wa...
Du hörst die nicht!
Der war rechts...
Der war irgendwo rechts im Container, ey.
Laut dem Sound.
Du hörst sie nicht.
Achtung, jetzt, ja.
What the fuck?
Wie geht das?
Wir haben beide vor uns gestanden.
Und volle Ladung Shotgun in die Fresse.
Was ist das denn?
Und ich hab eindeutig...
Ich...
Das Game ist...
Es regt mich schon wieder auf, ja.
Kann mir das irgendjemand erklären?
Aber wenigstens...
Wenigstens geht hier Riot...
Was ist das?
Alter, geh weg.
Geh weg!
wer mit was spielt. Ob Controller
oder Maus und Tastatur.
Ich glaube, daneben sieht man es.
Man wird wahrscheinlich nur mit den Leuten
gematcht, die das gleiche spielen.
Okay.
Ich glaube, das wird schnell langweilig.
Ich meine, es gibt, was? Vier? Drei?
Es gibt die Waldmap, die Map,
die Killhouse Map und was sonst noch?
Ich glaube, das war es, oder?
Achtung, wir machen jetzt wieder Big Brain.
Big Brain.
Okay, der kommt rechts.
Okay.
Das sind die übelsten Tryhards, Leute.
Das hast du schon gesehen, wie die rumjumpen.
Das hast du schon gesehen.
Wir machen jetzt wieder Middle Rush.
Perfekt. So muss das sein.
Pssiu, pssiu, pssiu.
Oh, Schneiber.
Oh, Schneiber, Schneiber, Schneiber. Schneiber Action.
Der was?
Ich habe bei dem nicht mal geschossen.
Was zum Teufel ist das wieder für eine Kacke?
P2P-Hosting-Dreck, Alter.
Was ist das?
Hat er den Müll gesehen gerade?
Ich war so was von drauf.
Ich habe dem so ins Gesicht geschossen.
Achtung, noch mal.
Fuck, die haben keinen Bock.
Achtung, huge, huge play.
Ach, meine Fresse, ey.
Das gibt es doch nicht.
Danke, klar, das ist schon.
Kein Quickscope.
Ja, die 60 Quickscope.
Normale Quickscopes gibt es nicht.
What?
Von wo?
Bam.
Rekt.
Au, ich darf mir nicht so auf die Finger hauen.
Also, einfach mal abgewartet.
5-3.
Okay, mit, mit, mit.
Was?
Was zum Teufel trifft mich hier die ganze Zeit?
Ach, da oben.
Ah, shit, da kann man ja hoch.
Das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee.
Das muss ich mir merken.
Können wir auf unserer Seite auch machen.
Okay, wir können das gewinnen.
Wir können das gewinnen.
Ich muss, ich muss die nur, ich muss die nur ownen, alle.
Okay.
Assault Rifle.
Alter, was ist das?
Noob-Tube.
Ich wurde genoob-tubed, oder?
Kann das sein?
Kann das sein, dass ich gerade genoob-tubed wurde?
Nee, nee, wurde ich nicht.
Was denn dann?
Oh, ich wurde genoob-tubed.
Achtung, Middle-Rat, jetzt.
Jetzt, gut, gut, play.
Hä?
Oh, nee, schon wieder genoob-tubed.
Gibt's doch nicht, ey.
Das gibt's doch nicht.
Oh.
Na gut.
Na gut, was willst du machen, ja?
Du kannst nur den 2-on-2-Modus spielen.
Auf nur den gleichen 3-Maps.
Ähm, tja.
Also, läuft's in 30 oder 60?
Also, es hat auf jeden Fall deutliche Drops unter 30.
Bei dem, auf manchen, in manchen Situationen.
Ähm, also ich würde eher 30 sagen, aber eigentlich läuft COD immer in 60.
Wahrscheinlich, 60.
Wahrscheinlich doch 60.
Ich würde sagen, normalerweise sind es 60.
Doch, das sind 60.
60.
Wobei, das fühlt sich schon ziemlich lecky an.
Wenn ich das so sehe.
Oh, wir haben diese komische, diese komische, ähm, Single-Schuss-Sniper.
Achtung, die werden jetzt geownt in der Mitte.
Wir strafen jetzt links raus und one-shotten gleich zwei.
Watt?
Hinter mir.
Jawoll!
Wallhack confirmed.
Pssiu, pssiu, pssiu, pssiu.
Ist das überhaupt eine Single-Schuss-Waffe oder könnte ich die einfach durchdrücken?
Okay, jetzt strafen wir rechts raus und one-shotten was.
Moment, ich muss mich heilen.
Na gut, da kannst du nichts machen.
Spritze ist Q, wenn man sie ausgerüstet hat.
Das ist random.
Das Loadout ist komplett random.
Jetzt habe ich auf Q, jetzt habe ich hier, äh, Alter, was heißt Q?
Äh, keine Ahnung.
Q halt.
Keine Ahnung, was das gemappt ist.
Was?
Alter, wo die alle immer herkommen, ey.
Außerdem ruckelt es zwischendurch.
Ja, LW Flip.
So sieht es aus.
Es fühlt sich langsam an.
Ja, doch.
Das ist aber gar nicht mal so übel.
Was willst du denn da machen, wenn du von beiden Seiten gerusht wirst?
Da machst du nichts.
Was willst du denn da machen, ey?
1M14.
Achtung, wisst ihr, was wir jetzt machen?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie die mich so schnell bashen.
Ich habe keinen Plattenschimmer, wie das von uns da.
Es gibt nur drei Maps, ja.
Hä?
Da war ich doch überhaupt nicht.
Es gibt nur drei Maps, ja.
Okay, kein Schimmer.
Fuck, das Objective.
Oh Gott, ich bin so dumm.
Da gibt es ja dieses kacke Objective in der Mitte.
Okay, ich muss mal kurz gucken, wie schnell der Kram schießt.
Geht so.
The fuck?
Was geht mir den Dudes ab?
Alter.
Was soll ich denn da machen?
Außerdem war mein Teammate 07.
Was geht mir der da?
Ja, ja, Voice-Chat ist an, aber ich habe Voice-Chat auch aus.
Ne, ich mache nicht Voice an.
Voice ist in jedem Multiplayer-Game übelst toxic.
Das war auch XX-Skull-XX, oh ja, 360-Skull.
Oh, da kennt man den ernsthaft.
Motion-Plur.
Oh ja, Motion-Plur muss aus.
Falls Motion-Plur wirklich ausgestellt werden kann.
Ne, geht nicht, weil...
General.
Ah, doch.
Weg.
Okay.
Also ich muss euch sagen, die Map, die wir vorher gespielt haben,
diese...
Ja, die, die, die halt vorher, die war besser.
Der wollte mich noob tun.
Man hört die echt null.
Man hört die Gegner gar nicht.
Zumindest nicht da, wo sie angeblich sind.
Gibt's noch Selfie?
Ja, wenn man's ausgerüstet hat.
Aber die Zusammensetzung von Waffen und Gadgets ist ja halt ziemlich random.
Rechts.
Outplayed.
Outplayed des Todes, ja.
Achtung, Grenade.
Der ist oben.
Der Dude ist oben.
Ich hab irgendwie das Gefühl...
Also entweder bin ich echt...
Also meine Reaktionen sacken einfach nur.
Oder es ist wieder P2P.
Weil bei dem hab ich wieder nicht geschossen.
Ich glaube, es ist P2P-Sacker-Kacke.
Richtig Boomer.
Der oben?
Ich glaub, der ist oben, oder?
Boah.
Voll ins Knie.
Was für ein Skyrim.
Achtung, jetzt hier.
Huge Play.
Bam.
Aber halt, was für den Aim wieder.
Was macht der?
Sich von mir killen lassen?
Keine Ahnung.
Ui, Schneiber.
Schneiber.
Links rausstraven und...
Haha.
Bam.
10-2.
Das war doch mal ne Runde, ha?
10-2, so muss das sein.
Der andere ist gleich wieder Instant Rage-Quiddle.
Ah, jetzt kommt der Chopper-Gunner.
Erstmal Chopper-Gunner rausrollen.
Wobei, Chopper-Gunner kann man schlecht nachmachen.
Das war eher...
Der TwoEats-Clan.
Mal gucken, ob's wirklich TwoEats wird jetzt.
Auch wieder diese Drecksmap.
Oh, TwoEats ist bei mir.
Der hat schon so einen Pro-Pro-Namen.
TwoEats?
Achmet Mubarak4411.
Anele.
Da kann nichts schief gehen.
Oh, Pump-Action.
Wir machen jetzt Big Brain Play.
Wir machen Big Brain Play.
Ich sag's euch.
Wir switchen Pistole.
Und treffen nix.
Lol.
Ha!
Ja, aber ich fand das Play sinnvoll.
Wir switchen wieder Pistole.
Sag mal, kann ich Pistole was treten?
Au.
Oh.
Ich bin schon mal weg.
Piss dich, Alter.
Der ist da oben, irgendwo.
WAH!
WAAA!
F...
WAS ZUM TEUFEL?
Ich hab den gar nicht gesehen.
Ich hab, ich hab ihn nicht gesehen.
Ach, von hinten.
Ha!
Fuck.
Outplayed.
Huge Outplayed.
Mega Outplayed.
Der ist da hinten.
Der ist immer noch da.
Der Dude ist immer noch dahinter.
Ja, der ist gehittert.
Gott.
Ja, nur diesen einen Modus.
Ja.
Das sagt ein bisschen.
Was für ein Headset ich habe im MMX 300.
Der ist fett gehittert.
Wow.
Oh!
Der ist oben gewesen.
Erwischt.
Two Piece.
Wie kommst du das so schon an zu spielen?
Also, jeder mit einer PS4 kann das spielen.
Und ja, der Sound ist mega komisch.
Wir müssen gleich mal...
Erinnert mich mal bitte daran, dass wir in die Sound Settings gehen gleich.
Wir gehen gleich mal in die Sound Settings.
Wir gehen gleich in die Sound Settings.
What the fuck?
Lol.
Er muss zum Objective.
Links.
Oder?
Ich habe links gehört.
Ja, am Objective ist der Typ.
Am Objective.
Objective.
Oder?
Da, links.
Links.
Da ist er doch.
Ich sehe ihn doch.
Oh.
Die Maps sind viel zu klein.
Boah.
Du hörst die Gegner so merkwürdig.
Ich habe den von hinten gehört.
Aber.
Aber drei Kilometer weg ey.
Oh, auf einmal ist er hinter einem.
Wartet mal.
Kann man irgendwas...
Nee, jetzt nicht, in der Runde sackt.
Oh, jetzt kommt Pistolenstelz.
Wie ich vorbeigerannt bin.
Der macht das hier jetzt da.
Der, der Ahmed.
Der Ahmed macht das.
Komm, Ahmed. Ahmed, Ahmed, Ahmed, Ahmed.
Ahmed, Ahmed, please.
Nein.
Ahmed macht das nicht.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir was reißen, du Jungs.
Jetzt müssen wir was reißen.
4-4, das können wir nicht auf uns sitzen lassen.
Wo?
Erwischt.
Eats, clap.
Okay.
Gut.
Wenn die alle zu mir kommen, ist auch in Ordnung.
Oh, huge. Zweiter Schuss, der war ja richtig.
Jaja, ich hab jetzt diesen komischen Adapter dran.
Ich hab ja mit PS4-Controllers sowas von krass gesackt.
Ich sacke zwar immer noch.
Kann er mal sterben?
Der ist oben.
Big Brain.
Naja, wenn man sich hinkniet, dann hört man es irgendwie besser.
Warum auch immer.
Nee, hab ich noch nicht.
Platz 93.
10-4, damit kann ich leben.
Also, wenn die Games immer in der Kategorie sind,
dann kann man sich wirklich nicht beschweren.
10-4, zwei Assists.
So ist das doch gut.
Ist eigentlich Ingame-Lautstärke gut?
USB.
Ingame-Lautstärke gut und sonst was passt das alles?
Nice.
Übrigens, ne, Leute.
Genau, Pharma ist mit Tigerstreifen.
Übrigens, Leute, wir haben ein Emote jetzt für alle Subs.
Nur mal so, ne.
Weil alle es noch nicht mitgekriegt haben.
Spielt sich das so wie früher?
Nö.
Das ist wieder die Single-Single-Schuss.
Okay, wir gehen jetzt, wir pushen jetzt rechts über das Ding
und stelzen sie voll weg.
Achtung.
Da oben ist er, ich seh ihn.
Hä?
Äh, ja, das war dumm.
Sound-Settings, Sound-Settings wollen wir gucken, richtig.
Äh, Options, Sound.
Und?
Äh, Mute-Controller-Sound, okay.
Audio-Mix, Flat.
Okay, was ist Flat?
Headphones.
Headphones ist besser.
Das hört sich schon viel besser an.
Was auch immer Flat war.
Ja, das hört...
Kann mir mal irgendjemand erklären, warum ich die nicht hitte?
Ich seh die überhaupt nicht richtig.
Hallo, Maus!
Der hat sich nicht gedreht nach links gerade.
Das ist keine Shotgun.
Das ist, das ist dieses Range-Ding, oder?
Äh.
Och, Mann, der Typ ist wieder gelöscht.
Das sagt doch.
Wisst ihr was?
Wir liefen jetzt auch.
Wie lieft man?
Options.
Ah.
Wozu sollen wir drinbleiben?
Two-on-One ist kacke.
Okay, guck mal, was gibt's denn nochmal für Sound-Settings hier?
Der Infinity-One-Mix.
Each Mix changes Sound-Balancing.
Dann wäre es doch sinnvoll, die Dinger nicht Headphones 1, 2, 3 zu nennen,
sondern,
danach, was wir tun, oder?
Weißte gar nicht, dass der Controller Sounds macht.
Weiter geht's.
Mich würde mal interessieren,
wie viel,
Noisman09,
Dankeschön.
Wird sprechen.
Leute, ich kann leider nicht nachgucken,
wer alles gesubbt hat.
Falls ich irgendjemanden vergessen habe zu erwähnen,
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich guck nachher nochmal nach.
Ich hab letztens übrigens eine 25 Dollar Donation verpasst
und ich hab meinen Donation-Link jetzt auch rausgenommen,
weil, ähm,
die Donation-Anzeige kaputt ist.
Die mach ich erst wieder rein, wenn die Donation drin ist.
Also, falls derjenige zuguckt,
der mir 25 Euro donatet hat,
Dankeschön für die 25 Euro.
Es hat's leider nicht angezeigt.
Okay, jetzt machen wir wieder unsere
Huge-Brain-Taktik.
Achtung, passt mal auf.
Huge-Brain.
Ich zeig's euch jetzt.
Oh ne, er hat mich geblockt.
Huge-Brain ist vorbei.
Das war Huge-Brain.
Das war richtig Huge-Brain.
Mit dem Unterschied, dass er mich gekillt hat.
Das war richtig Huge-Brain umflankt.
Nicht next level.
Aber nicht next level genug.
Ach, wir haben wieder Noob-Tube.
Jetzt aber.
Ich will, dass es mal klappt.
Scheiße, Mann.
Die machen das gut. Die machen das echt nicht übel, die Gegner.
Hat jemand
von euch eine PS4 Pro?
Und hat er schon mal gespielt?
Oh, jetzt hat er sie geonnt.
Mich würde interessieren,
ob die Auflösung...
Wow.
Ob die Auflösung besser ist.
Okay, jetzt sind wir auf der Seite.
Wir machen jetzt mal was. Ich hab ne Idee.
Haha, erwischt. Outplayed.
Ace, genau.
Machen wir nochmal. Das hat eigentlich ganz gut funktioniert.
Okay.
So geht's auch.
Outcamped.
Haben uns die Typen die erste Runde auch.
Die erste Runde haben die Typen einfach
im Spawn gestanden und nichts gemacht.
So, mal gucken, ob jetzt meine Special-Taktik funktioniert.
Die muss doch irgendwann mal klappen.
Okay, du machst das. Alter, du machst das.
Nein, macht er nicht.
Drei, zwei.
Übelster Skill-Action.
Okay, jetzt gehen wir rechts.
Ah, das Slider-End,
den müsste ich nochmal öfters verwenden.
Fuck, ich kack Noob, ey.
Musst du ja mal merken,
wo die Dinger sind, wo man sich dahinter stellen kann
auf der Map. Ich steh immer offen
und die Gegner stehen immer in der Deckung.
Das ist übelst... Nicht 5-Head.
Das ist low, low IQ-Plays.
Okay.
Outsprayed.
Wow. Du machst das, Kollege, du machst das.
Easy, easy win.
Warum war das kein Hit? Warum war das denn gerade kein Hit?
Rechts, rechts, rechts, rechts, rechts.
Ich hör ihn, rechts, Kollege.
Ja, beschreckt. Jetzt müssen wir aufdrehen, Leute.
Letzte Runde haben wir auch erst ein paar Runden
gesackt und dann 10-4.
Achtung, wir machen das jetzt anders.
Zack. Hol mal den Friseur ran.
Ich glaube nicht, dass der spielen will.
Okay, Shotgun-Action. Ach.
Ah, das...
Man müsste mal diesen
diesen super, super
Rennspeed verwenden.
Den benutze ich so gut wie nie.
Der Friseur will nicht. Kannst vergessen, er muss Black Desert spielen.
5-6.
Ah, wir haben alle. Guck mal, wir sacken alle.
Wobei,
50-50, KD ist nicht schlecht gegen
halbwegs gescheite Gegner.
Okay, da hinten ist einer. Kommt jetzt gleich, ja.
Hit.
Ich hab K... Ach, die machen das mit der Pistole.
Oh.
Ich musste unbedingt noch mehr
spielen, ey. Das ist eigentlich richtig
dämlich gewesen. Ich hab den dreimal getroffen. Hätte ich
den dreimal mit der Pistole getroffen, dann wäre er
dahin gewesen. Oh, nice.
Wow.
Huge. Der geht ab.
Hier. YZ-54.
Jawoll.
5-5. Jetzt kommt's drauf an.
Ey, bis jetzt macht's Bock, aber Cod macht
immer Bock, wenn's neu ist. Das wird aber nicht lange halten.
Ich mein, drei Maps und eins spielen, wow, das ist
bisschen... bisschen...
bisschen Sack. Wie, man muss nicht
mit... Ich hab's übrigens immer noch nicht
gecheckt, ob das jetzt ein Shotgun ist oder nicht.
Nice.
Das war Spitzrunde.
Damals seit Black Ops 1, ja.
Nice, nice. Ja, ich hab ja auch
überhaupt keine Ankündigung gemacht. Weder auf... weder auf
Twitter, noch auf YouTube oder irgendwo sonstwo.
Dass heut Cod
gespielt wird. Es macht schon
Bock. Manchmal buggt die Lobby.
Macht schon Bock.
Aber ich... ich glaube halt...
Also, wenn man das heute jetzt noch ein bisschen
spielen und vielleicht morgen noch eine Runde,
ich glaub, dann ist die Luft raus aus
wie gesagt, drei Maps und einem Spielmodus.
AC-130 hab
ich dann ausgerüstet. Ich hab nur Choppergunner.
Choppergunner,
Hunde und, äh,
Blackhawk. Gibt's
irgendwann eine PC-Beta, ja?
Äh, ich glaub, am 9. September
oder so? Warst du mal
wieder mit Kaboom beim Chinesen? Mal
wieder schon, das ist aber auch schon ein Jahr oder so,
ja. PC-Beta gibt's
glaub ich 9. September... 19, 19, glaub ich.
19. September.
Oh, nee. Sucker Map.
Ah, Shotgun.
Gut, Shotgun.
Wir machen das jetzt anders. Wir switchen jetzt auf Pistole,
gehen hier vorne hin und, und,
und shootern
schon mal was weg. Da lebt nur noch
einer. Der kann ja nur noch hier sein. Nice.
Nice. So muss das sein.
Oh, da. Da. Hardscopter.
Kannst du dich an das Homefront-Gewinnspiel mit dem
Sniper-Gameplay erinnern?
Ich weiß aber nicht mehr, was da gewesen ist.
Oh!
Puh. Da hätt ich nicht mit
der Pistole reinlaufen sollen.
Das war richtig schreckt.
Das war ordentliche Waffe.
Es ruckelt?
What?
Okay, der andere kommt links.
Also, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie der das überlebt hat.
Sinali, dankeschön.
Also, hallo
an alle Sinali-Zuschauer. Wer sehen will,
wer gerade übelst abkackt, diese Runde.
Aber wer gecarried wird
von Heim Mori,
der ist hier richtig.
Jetzt aber, hier.
Wir machen jetzt mal anders. Wir gehen jetzt auch mal links.
Ich glaub, das ist...
Der ist auch mit die Mitte.
Okay, der ist noch links. Der ist noch links.
Tja, Kollege.
So nicht.
Du hast dann das beste Sniper-Gameplay verlost. Mein Bruder hat das gewonnen.
Homefront?
Was gab's denn zu gewinnen damals?
Ein Game? Das Spiel?
Oh, Sniper. Sniper end.
Achtung jetzt hier. Huge, huge Snipe.
Huge Snipe.
Oh, fuck.
Was zum...
Moment, was hat man
hier am Start?
Okay, was auch immer.
Ich dachte, ich hab's gegen die Kiste geworfen.
Da ist er.
What? Wie ist der denn so schnell
dahin gekommen jetzt?
Fuck, Alter. Richtig reingesackt.
Ich wollte eigentlich auch direkt
zum Objective rennen.
Aber ich dachte, wenn er mich anhittet,
dann kann er nicht so schnell in der Mitte sein.
Aber ist er doch.
Ist der Wahnsinn.
Kann man so scheiße sein?
Jetzt wieder aufdrehen. Jetzt acht Kills in Runde.
Ach, Overtime war fertig.
Das war gar nicht das Objective.
Okay, was auch immer.
Oh, fuck. Das ist die Spritze.
Ich hab ne Spritze. Ich will gar keinen.
Okay, gut.
Jetzt wird auf... Ja, jetzt wird richtig...
Muss aufgedreht werden.
Am abkacken.
Vermisst du manchmal die Zeiten von YouTube?
Ja doch, wie es früher gewesen ist.
Definitiv. Aber so wie YouTube aktuell ist, nicht.
Es ruckelt übelst die Map.
Sackt. Huge.
Da war er in der Mitte.
Oh ne, schon wieder
die Kackspritze. Bin da noob. Ich dachte, ich hab...
Haha, Prefire. Bam.
Outplayed.
Doch. Also ich vermiss das schon,
wie es früher auf YouTube gewesen ist.
Aber so wie es aktuell auf YouTube ist, nicht.
Ah, hit it, hit it, hit it.
Wer ist da immer noch da, der Typ?
Gut.
Ja, ging doch noch.
Letzten Runden war wieder besser.
Kommen keine Videos mehr.
Doch, auf jeden Fall gibt's noch Videos.
Allerdings weiß ich nicht wann.
Also ich werd nicht mein Account löschen oder sowas Blödes.
Ich mein, allein schon, ganz ehrlich,
wenn ich mir in YouTube Deutschland so anguck,
was ich da vorgeschlagen hab,
irgendwelche Unge-Reaction-Videos.
Unge ist ja auch irgendwie zu dem geworden,
was er früher nicht leiden konnte.
Und noch viel mehr.
Also in Deutschland kannst du übelst knicken, ja.
Übelst knicken.
Im internationalen Bereich, find ich, ähm,
hast du bessere Chancen, was zu finden,
als in Deutschland.
Also, es heißt nicht,
dass es in Deutschland nichts Gescheites gibt.
Es gibt auch durchaus die ein oder anderen gescheiten Videos.
Aber,
ich finde, du hast einfach
vom Verhältnis von Bullshit
zu, ähm,
zu Nicht-Bullshit,
ist das in Deutschland schlecht.
Übrigens, die Granaten gibt's nur am Anfang nicht,
weil die Maps dann broken werden.
Okay, ich hab den Typ nicht einmal getroffen, ne.
Hör auf zu schnaufen, ja.
Jetzt erwischen wir einen.
Was, warum zum Teufel trifft das immer nicht richtig?
Das ist,
ja, das ist der Max das.
Der Max, der grad mit 0-1 übelst kacke ist.
Das ist der Max, ja.
Jawoll, jawoll, Kollege,
du machst das. Ja, sehr schön.
Übrigens, die, die, ähm,
Pistole ist übelst verbuggt.
Ihr habt das, ihr habt das grad nicht gemerkt,
weil man sieht das so, wenn man klickt.
Wenn du schnell, wenn du schnell tappst bei der Pistole,
dann queue die die Schüsse
und schießt nicht einfach, hört nicht einfach auf zu schießen.
Oh, meine Güte.
Ich bin so schlecht grad.
Bam!
Weggenubetube.
Was meint ihr, wie ist so, wie ist unser, unser Verhältnis?
So Win-Loss?
So 80 Win, 20 Loss ungefähr, hä?
Wie ist der Eindruck so?
Es macht Spaß, aber man kann 0
sagen zu.
Okay, keine Ahnung, was das wieder gewesen ist.
Das, das,
Kraft, das glaub ich dir nicht.
Jemand, der 0-3 abkackt,
dem ist nicht schön zuzugucken.
Ich weiß manchmal nicht, wie ich
das spielen soll, irgendwie.
Wollen wir ne Runde Shotgun?
Jawoll!
Weggeshotgunnt, so muss das sein.
Jetzt kann man wieder zugucken.
Man muss das eigentlich komplett ohne Scope
spielen, das ist halt ne stinknormale Shotgun.
Der ist oben.
Der ist unten.
Ja, jetzt hat man wenigstens gut gehört.
Du bist nichts, Max, doch, bin ich.
Immer guckt meinen Avatar an und guckt
den Subscriber-Avatar an.
Wie gefällt dir das Spiel? Das macht Bock.
Ha, den Kopf an.
Jetzt, jetzt machen wir was, jetzt machen wir was, Leute.
Fuck!
Von der Idee her war's nicht schlecht.
Ich wollte eigentlich mit, ich wollte eigentlich mit
der Shotgun da rüberjumpen, genauso wie der Typ ungefähr.
Das war auch mein Plan.
Plus, dass er schon
gestoppt hat und ich noch gerannt bin.
Wir machen wieder Shotgun.
Oh! Was?
Von wo?
Übelst geschwitzt.
Dachte, der hat's irgendwie nicht gecheckt.
Ach!
Der Rick ist wieder da. Du hast übrigens
einen Sub jetzt, ne? Ich hab's hingekriegt noch.
Okay, MP5, MP5.
Was sollst du denn da machen? Die machen das auch clever.
Eine von links, eine von rechts.
Da machst du nix.
Matchpoint, 4-5. Okay, wir müssen die Runde
jetzt gewinnen. Wir müssen gewinnen.
Die sind gar nicht wirklich viel besser.
Okay. Defeat.
Abgekackt. Hups.
Da kann man eigentlich direkt
direkt leaven, weil warum soll man sich
das weiter angucken, ne?
Next. Kann man eigentlich mittlerweile was
customizen?
Calling Cards, was haben wir denn hier so noch?
Tyrannosaurus schreckt.
Headbang Master Chief.
Apex Stelz.
Bis meine,
hab ich mir jetzt übrigens überlegt, bis meine Emotes alle fertig
sind. Ich hab ja, ich hab ja auf
Fiverr zwei Leute angeschrieben.
Und, äh,
wie nennen sie es da, ein Gig
gebucht bei denen für Emotes.
Werde ich jetzt einfach ein paar sinnlose
Meme-Emotes hochladen.
Okay, jetzt, jetzt.
Der eine ist rechts, das hab ich gesehen.
Ich checke das nicht.
Da nicht.
Ne, ich hab noch keine Emotes, ne, ne.
Wir haben auch ne Woche Zeit.
Ich seh die übelst schlecht, die
Geisha. Ich frage mich, ob das
wirklich nen Vorteil bringt, wenn man ne PS Pro
hätte. Ich seh die
übelst schlecht.
Und was mich fragen würde ist, ob die PS,
die PS4 Pro,
ob die flüssiger läuft.
Weil gerade auf der Map ist es ganz schön
hakelig. Ihr seht's glaub ich
zwischendurch, dass das ordentliche,
ordentliche Slowdowns hat.
Jawoll, jawoll,
jetzt. Bam.
Nein.
Shit.
Liegt an der Map bei mir. Okay, dann ist,
ja auf der Map ist es halt besonders auffällig.
Fuck, ey.
Was willst du denn da machen?
Voll in die Fresse. Der hat mir so krass
ins Gesicht genaildet gerade.
Rechts war er. Das sieht man schon.
Da jumpt er. Oh, gut.
Der kommt jetzt von hinten, klar.
Ah, nice. Win.
Easy. Gut.
Die sind beide rechts.
Ich seh nix.
Das ist mega frustrierend gerade.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wie ich das richtig spielen soll.
Dass die Uhr ingame echte
Zeit anzeigt.
Nö.
Wo ist der andere? Tot rechts. Oder?
Oder da hinten?
Hab ich doch nicht gesehen.
Muss erst mal gucken, wo da ne Uhr ist.
Wo ist da ne Uhr? Am Arm.
Ach, da am Arm. Da guck ich nicht so genau hin.
Ah.
Ouch, 3-3.
Der eine carryt übelst
da drüben, der Fussix.
Mal gucken, was gibt's jetzt für n Loadout.
MP7
und Desert Eagle.
What?
The fuck?
Es ist übelst random. Ich weiß wirklich nicht,
wie ich das kontrolliert spielen soll.
Geht das noch gar nicht?
Der macht wieder das gleiche.
Ich sag's euch. Der probiert wieder das gleiche.
Erwischt.
Okay, wo ist der Dude jetzt?
Da oben ist er.
Gibt's nicht. Ich lauf pre-fired
um die Ecke und ich bin tot.
Was ist das denn?
Na gut, der hat
besser geaimsort.
Aber der ist übelst low. Ein Hit und er ist down.
Ja gut, aber wir haben
weniger Leben. Kann er relativ gut
Sound tun. Ich hab da so meine
Probleme. Aber ich glaub,
das lag auch an den Sound-Settings am Anfang.
Komm, jetzt. Jetzt wird er aufgeholt.
Jetzt wird er aufgeholt. Oh ne,
jetzt kommt diese Shotgun-Geschichte wieder.
Okay, der ist schon mal schön angehittet.
Was willst du machen?
Ist das ein richtiges Cut von der Steuerung her?
Das ist schon richtig.
Sehr klassisch
von der Steuerung her.
Ixte, Moment, wie heißt der Typ?
Och, wieder. Unsere Lieblings-
Special-Killer aus dem Map.
Ixte
Onyx. Okay,
das ist wie gegen die
Hauptkampflinie.
Der ist da noch drinne.
Der war klar.
Sobald man weiß, wo die sind, ist das natürlich easy.
Nehmen wir einen Raketenwerfer.
Habe ich einen Raketenwerfer?
Ja, ich habe einen Raketenwerfer.
Ja, das muss man echt ausprobieren.
Okay.
Ich bilde mir ein, ich war vorher drauf.
Aber wahrscheinlich
hat er einfach gut Kopf getroffen.
Hast du ja gerade am Ende am Hitmarker gesehen.
Ja, nice.
Ach, ist wieder noch einer übrig.
Der ist wieder geragequittet, der Typ.
Warum ragequitten die Leute immer?
An Rage quitten wir jetzt auch.
Zwei gegen eins ist dumm.
Also zwei gegen eins war echt kein Spaß.
Quitten ist auch dumm. Warum?
Da können die nice one on one machen.
Oder können es sein lassen.
Das Ding heißt ja nicht umsonst
zwei gegen zwei. Also wenn sie sich
irgendwas bei gedacht haben, dann sollte das auch am besten
zwei gegen zwei gespielt werden.
Ich hatte zwar meine Zweifel, ob sie sich wirklich was bei gedacht haben,
aber man weiß ja nie.
Die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt.
Das ist keine Alpha für Vorsteller. Ne, ne, ne.
Das kann jeder. Jeder kann das
spielen mit einer PS4. Jeder.
Ne, oder?
Instant, instant
quitt.
Instant quitt. Das ist so dumm.
Das macht, das ist sinnlos.
Ich will das zwei gegen zwei spielen
und nicht eins gegen zwei.
Zum Download brauchst du PS Plus
wohlgemerkt nur mit einem deutschen Account.
Wenn du
einen internationalen Account, also jedes Land
außer Deutschland kann das Ding ohne
PS Plus runterladen.
Jedes Land. Außer Deutschland.
Und, ja.
Zwei gegen zwei. Sehr schön.
Der Typ geht
garantiert auch hier nach oben rausgucken.
Ne Ahnung. Ja, wegen Jugendschutz.
Jugend.
Jugendschutz.
Alter. Ja, was auch immer das jetzt
gewesen ist.
Der andere ist oben.
Ich hab den gesehen.
Ja, was willst du machen? Zurückschmeißen hätten
wir es können. Oh, nice.
Nice.
Vermaas.
Den Kopf.
Der ist auf der anderen Seite. Okay.
Gut.
Mir leuchtet das mit Jugendschutz auch nicht ein.
Aber das ist die einzige Erklärung, die ich dafür hab.
Gott.
Alter. Was ist das?
Zweimal in den Kopf geschossen.
Nope.
Das kann der ganz gut packen. Er muss den ein, zweimal
hinten, dann ist es vorbei. Jawoll.
Jawoll, komm.
Huge reflexes.
Ja, nice. Nice, nice, nice.
Ja, der macht das. Der macht das.
Anito. Ah, nee. Antonio, nicht Anito.
Was soll Anito sein?
Antonio.
Win. Easy win, easy life.
Oh.
Pssiu.
Das war übrigens ein Headshot.
Laut dem Hitmarker.
Wenn roter Hitmarker, wenn roter Hitmarker
ein Treffer, äh, Headshot ist.
Haha. Null.
Das war die schnellste Runde aller Zeiten.
Jeder links eingesniped, rechts eingesniped.
Sauen. Auck.
MonkaS.
MonkaGiga.
Puh.
Ragequit. Ragequit.
Ach Quatsch. 6-1. Leute, ich hab nix gesagt.
Ich hab nix gesagt. Die Runde ist vorbei.
Ich frag mich, warum die alle so krasses
Movement auf der Konsole haben.
Bin froh, wenn ich zwei Sticks
gleichzeitig bedient krieg.
GG. Ja.
Bisschen Menümusik wär schon nicht übel.
Ups. Ah, geht weiter.
Ah.
Ich find, das ist die beste Map.
Von den drei. Killhouse sagt,
dass die Waldmap suckt.
Das Ding hier geht halbwegs.
Okay, jetzt machen wir
den Omega Rush, die Omega Rush
Action linksrum.
Okay.
Ich hit den zweimal über die Range. Passiert nix.
Er hittet mich zweimal über die Range. Bin down.
Sehr gut. Sehr gut.
Pssiu.
Geh mal rechtsrum. Rechtsrum ist irgendwie sinniger.
Wisst ihr, wir machen jetzt
was anderes. Der ist hittet.
Der ist richtig gut hittet.
Fuck, der andere kommt jetzt.
Hit.
Der ist noch links rein, oder?
Okay.
Pssiu.
Ja gut, der hatte schon fett Damage drin.
Ne, du musst, wenn du
Playstation Plus
dann musst du deinen Ausweis scannen.
Ey, ich versteh das
nicht. Ich bin genau wie
der auf denen drauf, ja?
Aber ich verrecke.
Es leuchtet mir überhaupt nicht ein.
Ihr schiebt es einfach mal auf
sackiges P2P-Hosting.
Jetzt machen wir unseren, unseren
berühmten Middle Rush.
Und sterben dabei.
Aber rechts, Alter, der ist rechts, der ist rechts, Kollege.
Yeah.
Fuck. Bam.
Was war das?
Okay.
Warum haben wir gewonnen, wenn die sich gegenseitig
killen? Ich check das nicht.
Das ist doch...
Sehen die mich irgendwie früher, oder was?
Der hat mich...
Hä?
Der hat mich durch den Container laufen
sehen?
Ich hab ihn nicht gesehen. Ich check, also Mann.
Das ist so ne typische Cod-Geschichte, die ich einfach nicht
checke. Links.
Links, rechts, links, rechts.
Der geht ab. Remco
carried uns.
Was ist jetzt wieder?
What? War das mal anders?
Haben wir, hab ich irgendwas
eine Range-Waffe? Ah.
Guck mal, ich seh mein Ironsight überhaupt
nicht. Oh.
Ah, shit. Den hab ich
übrigens nicht gehört. Null.
Gehört.
Übelst washed up. Okay.
Keine Ahnung.
Mehr als draufschießen kann ich doch nicht.
Perfekt.
Alpha-Eindrücke.
Man kann nix sagen. Das ist...
Das sind drei Maps, ein Spielmodus.
Ich hab übrigens keine Ahnung,
ob das P2P-Hosting ist oder Dedicated-Servers.
Es fühlt sich ein bisschen nach P2P-Hosting an.
Achtung.
Da war was. Ich hab was gesehen in der Mitte.
Ja.
Geht doch.
Hacksaws.
Wallhacksaws.
Oh, jetzt werden sie, jetzt werden sie weggeschneipt.
Schau mal, gleich ins Hardscope gehen.
Achtung.
Was? Ich dachte, ich hab, ich hab,
ich hab ein No-Scope aus der Hüfte, ey.
Guck hier. Bam, bam, bam, bam.
Der Schuss ist nicht
mehr rausgekommen. Der Schuss ist nicht rausgekommen.
Achtung, Hardscoped.
Okay.
Ja gut, der hatte natürlich den Vorteil jetzt.
Das ist klar. Wenn du einfach nur wartest und stehen bleibst...
Lul.
Wupp, lul.
Oh, wir müssen das gewinnen.
Gleich ist 5-5.
Glaub nicht, dass der Typ das gewinnt.
Jetzt hier.
Jetzt kommt's drauf an.
Mal gucken, was wir für ein Loadout kriegen.
Oder Pistol oder sowas.
Wie? Achtung.
Wir gehen jetzt erst mal dahin.
Alter, Dude, Dude.
Hui.
Das ganze Game wirkt unscharf.
Also es wirkt übelst schwammig.
Also wenn das so bleibt,
und auch diese, das, das, das,
du siehst ja dein eigenes Ironsight nicht mal richtig.
Könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass man
tatsächlich nen nicht unerheblichen Vorteil
hat, wenn man ne
Playstation Pro hat.
Ich spiel das für dich mit Controller.
Reu dich. Richtig reu dich.
Also hat sich's.
Spiel.
Optik magst? Nee, nee, nicht Optik.
Face.
Wenn schon Face.
Ja, Motionplay ist aus. Mal kurz gucken.
Back.
Damage muss weg.
Ähm.
Damage muss auf jeden Fall weg.
Studierst du Dual?
Äh.
Studiere weder Single noch Dual.
Wir probieren jetzt mal was.
Leute, wir probieren mal was.
Kommt er hier?
Nee, Mitte.
Ey, Gott. Hast du mich gerade
algen, Alter.
Was man alles raushören kann.
Hinter mir. Fuck, wusste ich.
Ich hab's in dem Moment gehört, wo er getroppt ist.
Voll in den Arsch geballert.
Das ist, ja, das ist der Budget.
Das ist der Budget CS-Modus.
Tja, Kollege.
Ähm, die
Holzbanden, die da, ähm,
die da sind,
die sind sehr, sehr widerständig.
Du kannst da so gut wie nicht durchschießen.
Du kannst da so gut wie nicht durchschießen
durch das Holz hier.
Ich geh mal zu meinem Dude.
So geht das.
Siehste, der hat mir das letzte Mal in den Arsch geballert.
Jetzt hab ich ihm in den Arsch geballert.
No homo, no cuppa pride hier.
Bitteschön, ja.
Aber Moment, das ist ja ne Shotgun.
Oh, Megalul.
Warum macht der Dude mir über Range so krassen Damage?
Ich hab ihn zweimal über Range getroffen
und er trifft mich einmal
und ich bin fast tot.
Kann mir das irgendjemand erklären?
Das versteh ich nicht.
So spektakulär sieht das Game nicht aus.
Ich glaube, das liegt
unter anderem daran, dass man auch nicht zusammenspielt.
Der andere ist in der Mitte.
Ich muss mal zu meinem Dude.
What the fuck?
Okay, was auch immer.
Ich dachte, jetzt kann man so outplayen hier.
Ich glaub, der Dude ist oben.
Ich glaub, der ist oben.
Jawoll.
Der kommt rechts.
Was zum Teufel?
Wie geht das?
Ich aim den Typ ab, schieß drauf
und bei dem hab ich noch nicht mal geschossen.
Ich check das nicht.
Also das ist so diese typische Call of Duty-Dinger,
die man null kapiert.
Sollte es nicht Round One anstelle von Round Wind heißen.
Das vergess ich.
Englisch.
Das sollte Round Owned heißen.
Round Poggers.
Sollte das heißen.
Oh, die haben mich zugeerdreckt.
Oh, 4-4.
4-4.
Gott.
Kann man nur diesen Modus spielen?
Ja, leider.
Nur diesen Modus und nur 3 Maps.
Und keine Perks, Loadouts,
Killstreaks, irgendwas.
Das ist PS4.
Ja, es gibt es ja auch nur auf der PS4.
Ich spiele nie PS4, deswegen kriege ich Anfälle.
Alter!
Treffe ich die nicht, oder was ist das?
Ich schieße vorbei, oder Leute?
Ich schieße vorbei.
Zumindest nicht bewusst.
Ich war voll daneben.
Es ist auch wirklich gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Alter, stöhne nicht so rum.
Ich höre nichts
vor lauter Gestöhne.
Man hört nichts.
Es ist so mega für den Arsch.
Gachi Base.
Was jetzt?
Ja, okay.
Kaufst du dir das Game?
Sieht mega aus.
Man kann das überhaupt nicht einschätzen.
Also ich kaufe es mir auf jeden Fall nicht auf der PS4.
Ich höre da was im Voice Chat.
Will nichts im Voice Chat hören.
Auf der Switch.
So wie Switcher 3.
Man kann es ja mal probieren.
Fuck.
Der stöhnt so rum.
Ich höre nichts.
Ah, Mann.
Ich will wegstraven.
Die Gegner extrem schlecht.
Normalerweise
guckst du hin und du siehst einen Pixel rausgucken
und easy, easy
spotted.
Das kriegen wir noch.
So muss das sein.
Was schon?
Fast 3 Stunden?
Fast 3 Stunden online schon.
Was machen wir jetzt wieder?
War eine ganz gute Strat.
Nein!
Fuck, Munition leer.
Sonst wäre der gefickt gewesen.
Ja, aber gut.
Wenigstens.
Der war angehittert.
Der hatte noch 10 Leben oder so.
Oh, mal eine neue Waffe.
Cool, die hatten wir noch nicht.
Jetzt, huge, huge.
Ah, fuck.
Da machst du nichts, wenn die direkt neben dir stehen.
Da machst du nichts.
Du musst mal gucken, vielleicht finde ich noch ein paar,
die ich noch von früher kenne.
Dass wir mal mit ein paar gescheiten Leuten spielen können.
Oh.
Ah, huiuiui.
Abgecampt, ey.
Was ist mit dem No-Scope-Faktor?
Der ist bei Shotguns ziemlich hoch.
Ich habe gerade irgendwie 2 auf einmal verschossen.
Ich hatte keinen Schuss mehr.
Irgendwie 2 auf einmal verschossen.
Oh, 2 Leben zu 1 Leben.
Na, das kann ja was werden.
Aber der gewinnt, der mit 8 Leben.
Der campt sich jetzt irgendwo in der Ecke.
3, 4, komm.
Das geht noch.
So, man muss da Carry rausgeholt werden.
Was zum Teufel?
Wie geht das immer?
Ist der geslidet?
Ich habe den überhaupt nicht gesehen.
Du kannst die Alpha nicht downloaden,
weil du kein PS Plus hast.
Oder halt, also du brauchst,
in Deutschland brauchst du PlayStation Plus,
weil Jugendschutz, was auch immer.
Und international reicht es,
wenn du einfach downloadest.
Läuft's raus, Leute.
Oh, wir haben gewonnen.
Easy.
Du kannst den dann Fake, mach's wie ich.
Mach den einen Fake-Account in England.
Englischer Fake-Account.
Hat nicht, war kein Hit.
War kein Hit.
Ich check's nicht.
Das, warum war das kein Hit?
Das war voll drauf.
Sag mal Leute, schieß ich wirklich vorbei?
Vom Gefühl her treffe ich das fast jeder,
aber vielleicht sieht das jeder anders.
Es ist besser im Stream.
Aber meiner Meinung nach war ich dem grad voll auf dem Bein.
Ja, ihr seht das besser.
Selbst sieht man das immer schlecht.
Ey, du brauchst zum Onlinespielen kein PlayStation Plus.
Du brauchst nur in Deutschland zum Downloaden
PlayStation Plus. Das ist Big Brain.
Zum Spielen brauchst du kein PlayStation Plus.
Nur zum Downloaden.
Das ist richtig Pfeifherde.
Weil Jugendschutz.
Wir sind das einzige Land wahrscheinlich,
was so einen Müll braucht.
Oh Gott, ohne Mini-Rage nach dem Tod.
Ja, die Tode sind auch so merkwürdig teilweise.
Wo du dir so denkst, das kann's doch nicht gewesen sein.
Die Waffe ist schepp.
Oh.
Ich hab beim Übrigen auch schon wieder geschossen.
Ich glaub die Luft ist raus, die Runde spielen wir noch.
Das hast du auch in der Beta vom letzten Kot gesagt.
Ja, das ist halt auch immer so.
Du brauchst Playstation Plus zum Unterladen, ja.
War ich jetzt wieder nicht drauf?
Mit Emulator spiel ich grade.
Achso, der hat's überlebt.
Weil's hat keinen Hitmarker gegeben.
So, wir stürmen jetzt einfach drauf.
Scheiß auf Taktik.
In your face.
Ich hab übrigens noch nicht einen Nahkampfangriff gemacht.
Was ist das überhaupt?
V?
Ah, E.
Ich hab keinen Bock mehr, Leute.
Nix geschissen, ey.
Sobald ein Typ geflasht war.
Es ist übrigens frustrierend, wenn man mal was gerockt hat.
Voll auf den Sack.
Jawoll.
Einfach die ganze Zeit scheiße sein, das ist Next Level.
So geht das ja, so macht das ja Bock.
Ich glaub ich muss mich auch mal angewöhnen, den Slide
den Slide mehr zu verwenden.
Sitzt du im Rollstuhl?
Was?
Warum?
Ich hab einfach jahrelang nichts gespielt.
Vor allem schon gar nicht mal PS4.
Der Dude muss da rauskommen, klar.
Ja, outplayed, jetzt klappt's ja.
Jetzt funktioniert's.
Jetzt werden wir schon mal ne Runde campen.
Der andere kam links irgendwo, ne?
An was ist der denn jetzt verreckt?
An der Flash?
Ne, an der Semtex.
Adam sucht mal einen.
Gripp.
Bam.
Weggeschottet.
Geschottgunt.
Oh, Schneiber, Schneiber-Action.
Gut, Schneiber.
Da schleicht sich noch anderer Dude hier ran bestimmt, oder?
Mein Gott, ey, das kann doch nicht sein, dass wir
laufen von allen Seiten geowned werden.
Okay, nächste Runde müssen wir gewinnen.
Sollte mich gar nicht mit diesem komischen
Schneiber-Stelz auffallen. Einfach hier M13
raus und in your face.
Ach, Gott.
Fick. Kacke, ey, so dämlich.
Kommt das alte MW-Feeling auf?
Ne, das kommt, glaube ich, eher in Team Deathmatch auf.
Nicht wirklich.
Das ist auch ein bisschen doof mit
zwei, ähm,
nur zwei Verses, zwei
und nur drei Maps.
Suckt schon ein bisschen, ja.
Gibt es dedicated Servers?
Wahrscheinlich.
Manche Kills fühlen sich übelst Bullshit-mäßig an
und man kriegt natürlich auch mal wieder keine
Ping-Anzeige, was ja schon mal richtiger Müll ist.
Ich glaube, dass eine Ping-Anzeige
bei ganz vielen Sachen dazu führen würde,
dass man sich weniger aufregt, weil
du hast so diese Merkwürde, diese typischen Kott-Tode,
wo du halt weißt, du hast getroffen
und irgendwie hast du nicht.
Und wenn du dann wenigstens eine Ping-Anzeige hättest,
dann könntest du dir das doch halbwegs erklären, wo das Problem liegt.
Vor allem, wo ist eigentlich das Problem,
eine Ping-Anzeige anzubauen?
Ich meine, ernsthaft. Wo?
Was?
Warum?
Das ruckelt die Map, die ruckelt.
Da hinten ist er übrigens.
Hallo.
Hui, hui, hui, HD.
Vielleicht ist der Ping meistens Müll und sollte keiner sehen.
Also wenn die wirklich ordentliche Server am Start haben,
sollte der Ping eigentlich nicht Müll sein.
Jutsch, Noob-Toop, Noob-Toop.
Ah! Noob-Toop!
Lol.
ASMR
Kinder von Du.
So, so.
Ja, COD ist ja auch der übelste ASMR-Content.
Rechts.
Ich hab rechts was gehört, glaube ich.
Ne, links. Da sieht man mal, wie merkwürdig der Sound ist, ne?
Hab ich vielleicht mein Headset falsch rum?
Und deswegen ist der Sound so komisch.
Pschu, pschu, pschu.
Oh, nur Pistole.
Okay, einfach mal weggesprayt.
Ja, es gibt ja noch nicht mal einen Balken.
Komm, wir gucken mal. Kann man eine Ping-Anzeige einschalten?
Color-Blind. Wir machen einen Color-Blind-Mode an.
Color-Blind. Motion Blur.
Wow, Moment, es geht weiter.
Fuck. Piss dich, Alte.
Meine Güte, äh, gibt's doch nicht.
Gib.
Down.
2-2.
Ins Knie, jawoll.
One-Shot ins Knie.
Vermaas.
Pass mal auf, ich mach jetzt Trick 17.
Aha.
Ich seh die Ficker nicht.
Ich seh sie einfach nicht.
Das ist so schwammig.
Ich seh sie nicht. Warum hat der...
Dass der mich überhaupt gesehen hat, da oben.
Ich seh sie nicht.
Ich mach das nur anhand vom
Soundfest, wo er her schießt.
Ich seh nix. Ich seh null, wo der
hinschießt. Habt ihr da irgendwas gesehen gerade?
Der muss anhaben.
4-3-3.
Oh, jetzt wieder diese komische...
komische Schreckwaffe.
Moment, was ist geht? Molotow werfen, so.
Das war mal was, oder?
Und das war meiner Meinung nach drauf.
Aber nicht. Aber das war nice.
Der Jumpshot war nice, oder? Muss man zugeben.
Achtung, Achtung.
Wir machen jetzt Trick 17.
Hat er den jetzt erwischt?
Oder den anderen? Jawoll.
Trick 17 fängt an zu brennen, ne.
Kriegst gefühlt auch nicht immer
einen Hitmarker, wenn du drauf hast.
Das fühl ich seit der...
Das kommt mir seit der ersten Runde so vor.
Das sind teilweise ganz merkwürdige Hits.
Oder manchmal triffst du Dinger, wo du denkst,
im Leben...
Das ist jetzt ne richtige Shotgun, ne?
Was?! What the fuck?!
Was zum Teufel?!
Ich hab den zweimal geredet mit ner Pistole!
Wenn es Wunsch hat, dann bin ich mit ner Shotgun über die...
Oh Gott, äh...
WTF?
Die können irgendwie nur 3 Kilometer mit ner Shotgun schießen?
Nicht nett.
Okay, jetzt muss man gewinnen.
Wir warten jetzt kurz, und dann geht die Flash rein.
Okay.
Ich geb's auf, über die Range
mit was zu machen.
Ich verliere über Range alles.
Weiß nicht so genau warum, aber irgendwie jetzt über Range
krieg ich nix tot, mit den Dingern.
Und sterb jedes Mal.
Okay, Final Round.
Oh, ordentliche Waffe, jawohl.
Nice.
Ich mein, wie oft!
Wie oft muss ich treffen?
Fickt euch mal, ey. Meine Güte.
Ich mag's den Weitemal nicht. Geh jetzt off.
Mach jetzt Schluss.
Ich hab jetzt 3 Stunden gespielt, das reicht mir.
Komm, komm, das kriegst du hin.
Das kriegst du hin.
Easy win, easy win.
Seht ihr, wie das rumruckelt?
Nee, ich geh jetzt wirklich auf 3 Stunden, reicht mir.
Du bist frustriert, ich hab links was gehört.
Laser, laser!
Ah! Was machen die denn da?
Win!
Ja, morgen können wir ne Runde spielen.
Wie kommst du so generell mit PS4 klar?
Ich hab übelst
meine Probleme.
Total ungewohnt, ja.
Ich hab ja so nen Adapter, wo man auch
mit Xbox spielen kann, aber generell
ist halt
Playstation Aim ist halt gefühlt
also das liegt glaub ich irgendwie am Controller
aber selbst wenn ich den Xbox Controller an die Playstation
mach, ist das eher Scheibenwischer
wohin gegen
Xbox halt direkt ist.
Morgen mach ich Tastatur und Maus dran.
Morgen mach ich Tastatur
Oh, fuck!
Ich war noch in der Queue.
Morgen mach ich Tastatur und Maus
dran und dann probieren wir mal aus, wie sich
damit auf der PS4 spielt.
Wenn das denn überhaupt geht. Haben ja zu viele gesagt,
im Chat schon, das funktioniert.
So, jetzt machen wir mal wieder Trick 17.
Achtung.
Hehe.
Mua?
Nee, oder? Alter,
was ist das wieder?
Übelst nice.
Plates gemacht
und dann wirst du hier abgefarmt.
Das machen wir wieder. Das fand ich eigentlich ganz
sinnvoll. Der andere flankt
rechts. Okay, das hab ich
da hab ich jetzt vorbei geschossen.
Das nimmt mich ja nicht bei allem auf.
Wenn ich selbst vorbeischieße, ist das ja okay.
Oh, Schneiber.
Hardscope.
What?
Ihr könnt mir nicht erzählen, dass das nicht drauf war.
Das kann mir keiner erzählen, dass das
nicht drauf war.
Wir machen das jetzt anders. Wir packen jetzt die Pistole aus
und rushen die.
Hat keinen Sinn.
Ich will
eine Ping-Anzeige. Ohne Scheiße.
Ping-Anzeige. Weil ich hab bei dem
noch nicht mal geschossen wieder.
Ich will eine Ping-Anzeige. WTF?
Was ist das wieder?
Da kommt der Geschleide, der Dote.
Die machen das aber auch sinnig, die Gegner.
Das merkste. Also, du merkst gleich,
wenn du zwei hast, die ordentlich
können.
Machste nix. Da machst du echt
gar nix. Da kriegste, wirst
geschreckt. Da wirst du geschreckt
ohne Ende.
Das ist hier 06.
Okay, kein Hit.
Alter, da merkste halt, wenn
Gegner was taugen, dann bist du halt
wenn du so ein Playstation-Sucker bist
wie ich, kriegste halt auf die Fresse.
Oh, nice.
Immerhin.
Immerhin nicht 6-0.
Das Ding gefällt mir auch. Ist mal ordentlich.
ACOG.
Machste nix. Da machst du nix.
Gut, Leute.
Reicht für heute.
Ich glaub, morgen geben wir uns das Ganze nochmal.
Morgen geben wir uns das Ganze nochmal.
Und dann mal gucken.
Ich mein, das hat ja nicht viel Content.
Ist ja nicht so, dass man da jetzt
irgendwie
24-7 mal
für ne Woche spielen könnte.
Wobei, so lang geht das gar nicht.
Ich glaub, Sonntagabend ist eh Schluss.
Ich glaub, Sonntagabend ist eh vorbei.
Also, Leute, ich hab nichts gesehen
bisher.
Ich hab heute nix gesehen, was
Abos und sowas angeht.
Muss mal mein Zeug wieder umstöpseln,
dass ich was sehe.
Da guck ich doch mal schnell.
Da mal umstöpseln.
Den ganzen Müll hier.
Dann guck ich doch mal kurz rein.
Weil nicht, dass ich jetzt irgendwie
zig Leute übersehen hab.
Das wär natürlich nicht so nice.
So. Gucken wir mal.
Ach nee, ich kann ja hier gar nicht gucken.
Muss hier drüben gucken.
Streamlabs.
Steamlabs, Streamlabs.
Also, wen haben wir denn hier heute?
Ähm, den.
Den Martin haben wir.
Den Elevencore. Noisman09.
Äh, Ovi...
GVOZ13
Crescendo, den kenn ich schon. Er ist öfters am Start.
Er ist auch wieder neu dabei. Wahrscheinlich zwei Monate.
Ich seh's jetzt hier nicht mal.
XFACEL7, der HydrogenYoyo.
Tainzer.
Und der Casinokapitalist. Dankeschön.
Für alle Twitch Prime Subs, wo wir jetzt grad dabei sind.
Das muss jetzt nochmal sein.
Ähm.
Für alle, die heute subscribt haben.
Und auch danke an alle, die gefollowt haben.
Haben wir sicherlich auch ein paar.
Muss ich mir mal angucken.
Recent Events.
Ähm. Follow, follow.
Ja, dankeschön. Follow hier.
Aber auch, haben wir auch jede Menge.
Dankeschön für die Follows.
Für die ganzen Subs.
Die können wir ja auch mal vorlesen.
Aber es gibt jetzt nochmal eine Runde.
Und natürlich für die ganzen.
Für QChat.
So, Leute.
Ich glaub übrigens,
mein Chat ist verreckt.
Ähm.
Ich seh keinen Chat mehr.
Jetzt geht's wieder.
Für TF.
Ich glaub, das ist übelst roh, als rübens abgespannt.
Ähm. Ja. Danke für die ganzen Subs.
Wahrscheinlich bin ich morgen wieder am Start.
Muss ja.
Ich glaub, keiner geschrieben hat.
Und.
Dann schauen wir mal, wie's läuft.
Das war heute schon.
Das war mir schon wieder typisches Call of Duty
geraget Deluxe.
Die ganze Geschichte.
Und sehr merkwürdig Sachen wieder
passiert zwischendurch.
Und ein paar mal übelst gerollt worden.
Ja, macht's gut, Leute. Wir sehen uns.
Bis morgen.
See you.